sure it might just be a prologue but
Metal Gear Solid 5 Ground zeroes is an
important milestone for the stealth
genre it has taken the series to an
open-world playground and redefined how
stealth works within that largest scope
and in doing so they found a way to make
failure fun little fairy isn't a
self-camera
always just around the next corner you
know don't get spotted don't make noise
moving through the world you're always
balancing on the knife's edge
that's why stealth is tense but some
find it too punishing
I can understand that you know it's
frustrating when a stealth game throws
you into a game over screen if the enemy
so much as sees your foot sticking out
from behind a crate so recent stealth
games have started focusing on how to
approach failure design that means
they're trying to make themselves feel
less abusive to you when you mock up now
they do this by replacing reasons to
simply load a savefile with gameplay
mechanics that allow you to respond to
failure in new and interesting ways
you've probably seen some recent stealth
games making a big fuss over how they
now just kind of let you shoot everyone
that's one way of addressing failure
design by making combat controls tight
and accessible Splinter Cell blacklist
did it do
hitman absolution did it
even the new thief tried to better
support combat but why would you want to
sneak your way through if it's just as
easy to pull out a gun and shoot your
way through Ground zeroes has the answer
by giving you the chance to turn every
little mistake into an opportunity the
sheer scope of ground zeroes open world
creates this vast playpen of
interconnected systems that exist to
nudge you closer to failure getting
spotted or creating a loud enough
disturbance completely disrupts the
behavior of enemies across the entirety
of camp Omega the sense that you're
actually infiltrating a large location
is all the more real when that location
exists without load screens and when the
consequences for disturbing the enemies
within that space are felt across its
entirety because this larger location
means that you've got way more chances
to mess up ground zeros removes the
series iconic radar and replaces it with
the ability to spot enemies and track
their locations through walls the
failure of alerting enemies all making
them suspicious becomes fun because the
work you put into marking those enemies
allows you to poke and prod at the enemy
AI with intent want to get through a
heavily guarded area no problem
plant some c4 charges on the opposite
side of the base
sneak back to the guarded area detonate
the explosives and watch the markers
above all the enemies you've spotted
leave their posts to investigate giving
you the opportunity to slip by but what
if one of those guards catches sight of
you as he's running to investigate the
explosion
ground zeroes new reflex system is
designed to account for this small
self-contained failure the game goes
into slow motion and you've got a few
seconds to take the gun out before he
radios in and alerts the entire base
it's a fantastic piece of failure design
because it takes the games polished
action controls and gives you the
opportunity to correct the situation
with a bullet to their face but it's not
a free kill you still have to deal with
the consequences like the sound of
gunfire or having to hide the body and
what's fascinating about ground zeroes
is how its open-world gives these
consequence
is the scope to spread out like a
butterfly effect check out this example
here I've been tasked with killing two
specific enemies while trying to sneak
up on the first I get spotted so I have
to take him down quickly it doesn't go
so well he goes down but the enemy knows
I'm here with camper Omega alerted I
know that the second target will try to
flee which will actually fail the
mission so in a panic I sprint to the
nearest armored vehicle when who do I
see but my second target trying to drive
off energy right next to me
not only can I easily shoot him down but
now I've got the perfect mode of
transport to escape the hail of gunfire
that's about to descend on my location
small failures in ground zeroes can
snowball into something worse but you
always have the chance to deal with the
situation and even turn failure into
opportunity and that is the heart of
good failure design